Joe Biden dropping more hints on a
potential 2024 run that was Helix by the
way but he better watch his back one
house Democrat claims hundreds of Dems
think it's a mistake but they can't say
it out loud or as he puts it quote
believe me there are literally hundreds
in Congress who would say the same thing
but they simply won't bleeping say a
word
Dana
what do you think that word was that we
bleeped I don't know can you tell me in
the commercial yes but the hell with
that Biden seems to be going full speed
ahead and even testing out his 2024
message at a Democrat retreat
if we did nothing
nothing
but Implement what we've already passed
and let the people know who did it for
them
we win but we're Way Beyond that it's
not just about winning the mega
Republicans are not going to get on
board for most of these things
but that leaves a lot of Republicans
that are still left
no by the way watch
I predict watch Watch What Happens
Republicans can help make a significant
majority in some of these things
all it's missing is the little banjo him
sitting on the bridge playing the banjo
believe me yes for fans of Deliverance
Jesse uh we we went through a lot of
rumor mongering into the Trump
Administration like people always say oh
there's a tantrum in the West Wing this
hundreds of people in the Congress do
you believe it
stand it so I'm going to identify as a
Democrat okay and here I go
you're my leader won more votes in the
history of the United States
so they say he got the Rust Belt and not
only that he got Arizona and he got
Georgia and then he kept the senate in
the midterms he signed a few Big Ticket
bills and he beat the guy on the
Republican side that's supposed to be
the front runner for the next election
so you got that going for you with some
decent jobs numbers and low unemployment
so if he doesn't run on the other hand
you have no bench you have Pete you have
Kamala and you have a pathetic bench and
what are you going to do then you're
going to primary Joe Biden and just pick
your scab on national TV
oh my God so if I just run with the guy
give me the old white male and just run
it again right
but it looks like the corporate media is
bored of the guy the corporate media
knows Joe doesn't rate Joe doesn't leak
Joe doesn't do interviews well he
doesn't leak information he doesn't leak
information thank you for clarifying no
Democrat would say that there's there's
no glamor in the White House and he's
bad for business so they're trying to
move him out
and then you have my family Democrats
and no thrills are going down anyone's
legs there he's the Trump Slayer that's
it so people are trying to he said he
was going to be a placeholder people are
trying to hold him to that promise and
it's starting to get a little awkward
Dana this is interesting it seems like
there's a game of chicken going on
between the Democrats and the
Republicans and they're both driving
cars they're not crazy about yeah right
I've seen in my lifetime and what's
happening is there is a power vacuum and
when there's a vacuum it creates chaos
so because he hasn't announced yet and
he's like I guess maybe if they want to
have some big rollout in April or
something they have the they have the
first lady on a foreign trip
sneaking into an interview that he's
going to run that was obviously a tell
they to give a speech at the State of
Union where he says we're going to
finish the job seventeen thousand times
in one speech he said finished the job
so that was a tell as soon as President
Biden says he's running again then all
of this will end but they I think they
probably have a pretty high tolerance
for pain at the White House to just sit
there and be like wow come like it's
smacked in the face by every day by
another Democrat and now you have that
Democrat from Minnesota he was actually
on the record you have to admire that
because very few of them are willing to
do it what do you think judge I mean
there's still two years away this is
it's just two I mean we we see how Joe
Opera Joe doesn't look
he does he's not operating at top form
but look the person who knows best Jill
yeah she'll get him better she'll walk
him around and she'll make sure that
when he's on stage he faces the right
direction we can all be comfortable that
Joe's going to be just fine and the
truth is that he's going to say he's
going to run no one's going to tell him
not to run he's just going to say it and
that's going to be the end of it the
question is what's going to happen in
the next two years how is he going to
behave are Americans going to feel
better or worse if inflation is you know
still a problem and gets worse and 80 or
70 percent of the country thinks we're
going in the wrong direction you know
then the question is you know they when
they look at two candidates and there's
so much that's left in terms of you know
who the two going to be who are they
going to be and then Americans will
decide but I can't imagine he doesn't
just disintegrate a little more over the
next two years I don't understand half
of what he says yeah neither does he you
know Jessica do you get the feeling that
it's going to be a 2020 replay
increasingly yes I think the last week
has felt very pro-trumpy I mean there
were a bunch of polls that came out that
showed that where DeSantis had been kind
of gaining now he's taken it back and we
do know that his primary base is his
base right that 25 to 30 percent and
they show up to vote so they're going to
have to be organized whatever the
opposition is to him has got to get that
in order it can't be the 16 people up on
stage because everyone's going to take a
couple percentage points and then you're
gonna have Trump again if that is what
the party doesn't think is good for them
we saw Mike Pence was interviewed today
or yesterday and said I don't think he's
going to be the nominee when he was
asked if he was going to support him so
I don't know but it does feel
increasingly reduxy at this point I
think Jesse you played a decent Democrat
um I think it was my influence I heard a
lot of my own scripture repeated there
um but I do think in terms of what the
chattering is behind his back it has
nothing to do with the policies or the
content I know the presidency it's an
age concern just that you're going to
have someone if he wins a second term is
finishing at 86 years old and that's old
right this isn't one of those questions
like you know what what exactly are you
worried about
that people naturally slow down this is
a this is a high energy job and it has
to be and he still is I mean out of his
prime
yeah actually
yes
but the State of the Union which he was
getting a lot of compliments even from
people on the Republican side huge
Energy Great delivery and then he spent
an hour and a half afterwards working
the Rope line talking to everyone taking
selfies that wasn't a man who needed to
be put to bed by his wife you sound like
a proud mom after the baby just had a
boom no he was trying to figure out
completely regular everything is fine he
made he made it all the way to the toy
toy
I'm sorry but I'm not sorry right that's
the problem with your apartment making
me nervous that you're gonna follow me I
know I should stop doing that no please
continue yeah all right hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now